charlie à remporter une grande
compétition régionale de cuisine il ya
deux ans c'est un génie de la cuisine
charlie tu vas sherbrooke demain soir il
y aura tout le monde
génial je pourrais peut-être en profiter
pour leur dire que je vis chez mes
parents alors qu'eux ils vont créer leur
boîte et la fille du café pourquoi les
bienvenus dans et capable
tu es charlie preneur oui s'il ya un
problème
bonjour je tenais juste à te dire que
voilà je te vois ici chaque fois que je
viens et je trouve que dans aller à la
prochaine
ça aurait pu être pire je ne crois pas
salut je voulais juste salué après ce
qui s'est passé tout à l'heure dis moi
pourquoi tu travailles dans un cinéma et
pas dans un restaurant tu crois que je
ne vois pas ce qui se passe autour de
moi ça me terrifie de me contenter de ça
et de ne pas arriver à m'en contenter
[Musique]
je te comprends pas c'est vrai quoi tu
es intelligent tu t'es sympa et côté
marin je suis pas bon c'est peut-être
pas volontaire parfois quand bien même
c'est difficile il faut agir
c'est comme ça la vie
on dirait un mauvais slogan
c'est marrant tu sais c'est la seule
fille kim et laisser penser que j'avais
du chat mais qu'est ce que tu as
j'essaie juste de me provoquer un
anévrisme n'a aucun charme
c'est le problème je sais
[Musique]